what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and it
looks like today we could possibly have
our biggest spider-man no way home
league to
date a spider-man no way home league
that shows us
tom holland spider-man andrew garfield
spider-man and toby maguire's spider-man
now we're gonna talk about whether or
not this is indeed real or if it's a
crazy good photoshop we also have
another picture which some of you might
have seen if not you are going to be in
for a real treat in this video we're
gonna break it all down and seriously if
you are trying to avoid spoilers for
spider-man no way home you should click
away now because i'm not lying when i
say that this is possibly if it's real
the biggest leak that we've ever gotten
for any superhero movie so possible
huge gigantic spoilers coming up for
spider-man no way home also if you love
spider-man i am giving away a spider-man
collectible all you gotta do is
subscribe to my channel and cosmic
culture and leave some comments on some
recent videos so this leak came in a
very weird way we have two leaks two
different photos and this first photo is
mind-blowing it is of the three
spider-men together tom holland
spider-man toby maguire spider-man and
andrew garfield spider-man now i'm not
sure if this photo is real or if it's
fake but in case it is real i hope you
all can understand that i can't show it
too much in case it's real because i
don't want to get in any trouble i'm not
trying to get anybody else in trouble
and i'm not trying to give the studios a
hard time but the odds are if you're
here watching this video you've most
likely seen the photos already i mean
they are everywhere online right now on
twitter on instagram but we are going to
talk about these photos because if they
are real they actually connect to some
other supposed leaked photos as well and
let me explain how these came about a
well-known person in the community i'm
not going to say his name because i
don't want him to get any hate or get in
any more trouble than he is even though
his name is watermarked onto the photos
i'm not going to say it but this person
posted them apparently thinking that
they were actually fake now there's a
lot of debate going on about this right
now but really the only thing that
matters is are these photos real or not
and so far online some people have come
out and said yes they are real grace
randolph herself even stated on her
twitter yes they're real so this looks
like it's the first time we're actually
seen toby mcguire andrew garfield and
tom holland spider-man all together now
it still could be fake the person who
posted them claims that they are fake or
at least they thought they were fake but
then once everything started to kind of
get traction and go down they took them
off their twitter i'm really leaning
towards the fact that these are indeed
real and here's kind of my reasoning as
to why they're real this scene in this
leaked photo of the spider-man together
is a scene that we've seen in other
leaked photos in this photo that is
leaked of the three spider-man the three
spider-man are on top of something near
a body of water and there is railing
behind them behind them is two-barred
railing where else have we seen
two-barred railing with andrew garfield
spider-man and toby maguire spider-man
well we've seen it in the most popular
leak so far of andrew garfield a leak so
popular that andrew garfield and jimmy
fallon talked about it on the jimmy
fallon show now andrew garfield denied
that it was real but at the same time he
said he had never seen it and then said
he saw it and as i've always said these
actors can't just come out and say oh
yep that's real you caught me they can't
do that so andrew denying he's in the
film means nothing especially after
these leaks because this appears to be
the exact same location now the
background for the other leaked photos
was blue but that's just because it's a
blue screen they're going to add cgi
graphics behind it the biggest part is
that it is the same scene where they're
on this railing this is apparently a
scene where all three spider-man are
going to come together and the reason
that i think this photo might be leaning
more towards real is because this scene
right here photos of it have been leaked
before and now more are coming out if it
was a completely new different scene i
would be a little bit more skeptical but
it seems like there's a person out there
who was possibly working on this scene
took pictures of it as it was being
filmed and now has pictures of it in
post-production and if it's real
somebody is definitely in trouble but
honestly this is a dream come true for
fans if it is indeed real this is a huge
confirmation of the other two spider-man
being in the film now i know we've had
so much evidence pointing towards toby
maguire showing up and andrew garfield
showing up i mean they already have
revealed that spider-man no way home is
going to be a multiversal film they've
already revealed doc ock green goblin
sandman electro and we've gotten just so
much evidence from other leaked photos
but i know even still with the people
who believe they're going to be in the
film probably still have a little bit of
skepticism in them but this really just
takes it over the top in a huge
confirmation now there is another photo
and this one is seemingly real as well
and it's of a scene that was described
in a recent plot leak this scene is of
four people sitting at a table together
it's peter parker happy hogan aunt may
and matt murdock and it is charlie cox's
matt murdock now i talked about this
scene not too long ago in a plot league
from what we have heard from that pot
league this is a scene where the four of
them are sitting down together and they
are talking about what it's like to be a
superhero now i originally thought that
this was going to be toby mcguire or
andrew garfield because if it's a
superhero conversation and tom holland
is talking about what it's like to be
spider-man then i kind of assumed that
another spider-man would be there as
well however it looks like i was wrong
and it's matt murdock now this would
seemingly confirm that matt murdock is
indeed going to be peter's lawyer in the
beginning of spider-man no way home now
i've been told that charlie cox is only
in one scene in spider-man no way home
i'm not sure how true that is but my
source is usually pretty accurate so
this would apparently be that one scene
now since the leak said that they're
sitting at the table talking about what
it's like to be superheroes it makes me
think that matt murdock might actually
reveal that he's somewhat of a superhero
himself now having said that i actually
don't really think that's something sony
and marvel would do i actually think
that they're going to hint at this after
all they can have a conversation about
how hard it is to be a superhero peter
can lead that conversation and matt
murdock can simply say that he kind of
knows how that feels or he can imagine
how that feels because based off of
everything that we've learned so far and
everything that the plot leaks have said
matt murdock is going to be the one in
spider-man no way home and not daredevil
meaning we'll see matt murdock but we'll
never see him put on his daredevil suit
and we'll never see him in action either
this is kinda gonna be like an
introduction to the mcu for him kind of
like a hey audience he's there he's in
the mcu now but you'll see him a little
later on during the echo series so these
leaks are pretty big like i said
definitely the biggest leaks that i've
ever seen if they are indeed real which
again kind of really seems like they are
and man do they just get me so excited
for this film it's going to be
absolutely insane heck this might be
bigger than avengers end game looks like
we're in for a huge crazy ride but let
me know what you think in the comments
down below thank you all for the support
that you've been giving my channel i
absolutely love making these videos for
y'all and i'm glad you like them as well
if you want to interact with me you can
always follow me on twitter and tweet at
me or you can follow me on instagram as
well and leave some comments on some
photos and now i'm on tick tock so hope
to see some of y'all on those platforms
as always like the video if you enjoyed
it and don't forget to subscribe so you
can enter that spider-man giveaway and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof